ねえた
寝てたんだね
わあああじゃあなぜそうでというわけで
復帰そうそうなんですけれどもチャンネル
お休みしてた時もちろんなら休んでたりだ
かお仕事で撮影とか色々好きなんですけど
もう以外方が健康を気遣ったことも結構
やっておりましてその中でとてもずうな
ものおっツアーでございます人間ドック
いった川の学生さんたちはちょっとお
なじみがない言葉かもしれないですけど
もう車外に出ると皆さん人間ドックという
ものがありませんまぁ簡単に言うと健康
診断ある誰か学校抜けで植菌5人ら健康
死んだなもっとしっかりしたバージョン
みたいな感じで学校にいる時はの健康診断
とか出なかったバイトし順調体長を測っ
たり白く警察はいろいろあると思います
けども大人になったらそういうのなくなっ
ちゃうわけですよそれでもちゃんとし診断
しないと魔女は金どうしても浮かんあっ
たらにもう2年前とかでも早期発見に越し
たことはないからちゃん毎年人間ドック
行かせてもらってるんですけどもその結果
が帰ってきました
あみ軽い
いやーのまだまだ味せないので今ここで
はじめて上げます
どうなるでしょ一羽の僕去年一年がご飯を
軽視していたんでねそれ超太ったとかない
と思うんですけども
その分ラーメン食ってたなんで来てるんで
そのところがどう響くか
そして再掲さがあるかまってまって大丈夫
かめっちゃか文字見えたんだけど
大丈夫かというと俺の周りの人でお礼が
聞いたところだとなんか大地くんが言う月
再検査たみたいですが胃にポリープが出来
てるみたいな
笑い事じゃないんですマジで笑えないこれ
で何か異常があったらワンチャンば
チャンネル九州まであるからてぃ発見し
なきゃいけないんでしっかりとチェーンさ
せていただきました見ていきましょうぞ
[音楽]
ん
分
おやちょっとっ
大丈夫かこれは去年よりはるかにダメです
みたいな所が増えてるぞ
[音楽]
西いまってよ来い基本やばいやばやばい
ちょっと待って待って待って待ってっ者の
ん
マジ
まあ
や by ちん子初の再建される
待って待って待ちじゃあ屋さんじゃなくて
しょうがないんですよ見てください今回の
検診の結果再検査精密経営者女子が必要と
なりました
コーン
と子だね歩数だけのせいじゃないけど
ちょっとやばいな体に形が来てるって事か
筋を通しお願い結果向けてますねとこちら
です上間ってめっちゃおい山なんか秒3と
脂質代謝と肝機能の最中させるので3つか
3つかマジかマジかよ
そうだ
嘘じゃねーけどマジかよ
japan やばい
やばい5せませんちょっとあの人生初すぎ
て結構
慣れてまして今からだが悪いですって
コードもはっきり言われると
なんかまずで生活
見返した方がいいんだなと思います
細い体た後で見るんですけど何時見ていき
ますこれが bmi ってやってよくある
中の太ってる中からの死亡てになれで5年
前から人間ドックやるようになってて
明らかにっぺとって言ってるなんていうの
はわかります血圧も最悪じゃねぇなんか
今年でパワーが出ました去年までの中に
落ちて来てたの最悪血統とかよこわかん
ないでコレステロール値もめっちゃ高いし
て中性脂肪もう何かなんとなく分かって
です日本賛同したでもちょっとは no と
言うねちょっとストレスがたまる日々が
続いた時は汗これに頼った時もあった正直
に話します人間ドックの前日は飲んだりし
ちゃダメなんですよ食べたり飲んだり結構
事前に控えてるんですけども人間ドックの
2日前なんかケースきたちょっとバカ騒ぎ
してあのんでた気がするんですそれのせい
だと思いたいまぁどっちにしろかなり
ヤバイ値なのはわかります
true
困ったなぁちょっといろいろ見ていき
ましょう身長
今回1806.1ボカシ986雪体重73
店さんへ前回より3キロ増えてしまいまし
たあのご飯禁止会員上されてば工夫した
結果ですねこれはまだ表全体13級くらい
低いのでまあまあもうちょっと痩せます
肥満のマイナス3.8肥満ではないと
pmi も21大絞りずう7.0お腹周り
が3センチメましたデブです血圧視力まま
まあまあ前とかん
なんか大丈夫秒ゲートですね蛋白が無難か
毎年すごい中ズってきてるんですよ
マヤさしこってで肝機能なクレアチニン
って言う奴がなんか基準値をオーバーして
はじめ高くなってますあと尿酸も8.0
大丈夫いいいって書いてるって事はこれ
めちゃくちゃいいんじゃない後は8脂質
代謝がもうやばいなー総コレステロール値
が今回爆発的に悪くなってるヤバいぞ中性
脂肪もうんあと去年よりかは減ってるんだ
ビル dl ってユーザーはがっなんだろ
ldl ってその後に調べてみます
こんななんか hdl 度は ld 8割
と思ったかわかんないんだよ納豆代謝は
ちょっと仲良くなってるぽいですねなん
だろサウナのおかげかなんで肝機能なに
これいいえいいめっちゃ肝臓悪いかね
デートなんか貧血とか白血球と変わったり
大丈夫だったっぽいですけど月桃つが高い
状態東米軍年は生活の見直しテルミンが歌
してしましょう本当にあのお酒飲む機会は
前回よりずっと言えました米解禁という
ことでオムライス屋さんにお答え作ったと
帰り道でコンビニでカレー食べた騎士団で
かなり近くはありましたすいませんねます
ことでこんな真っ赤なことあるでも増え
てるんですけど普通にはいというわけで
ちょっと結果が相当ヤバかったので
とりあえずあの
未だに伝えてみますそんなやはりの誰も
知らないと思うから普通にビックリストと
いう薬草すんだろう
[音楽]
申しますお寿司お疲れ様ですはい
当然あの動画撮ってるんですけどいいです
か
ちょっとだけちょっとだけちょっといる
ちょっとだけなのですねー
人間ドックの結果
尿酸
あ脂質代謝
肝機能
計3つの項目の再検査精密検査が必要だと
いうことが分かりました
カジャナ
ブーバしょーううーー
[音楽]
ドゥ
あった
[音楽]